ne pouvant pas accueillir du public la
barbacane s'est organisée pour rendre la
culture accessible à tous l'exposition
corpus corus crée autour de l'univers du
danseur et chorégraphe olivier dubois
est visible uniquement depuis
l'extérieur
l'idée est vraiment de plonger dans le
corps de voir des images des gens en
mouvement parce qu'en ces périodes
compliquées ça nous manque
nous sommes très contents de présenter
cette exposition
[Musique]
je
l'exposition se compose de huit photos
présentant différentes pièces d'olivier
dubois
il ya également un reportage sur
l'univers de ce chorégraphe et quelques
planches viennent s'ajouter à la
collection où l'on découvre des
notations de chorégraphie les vitres de
la du bâtiment ça un autre encore écran
mais ça permet d'être plus dans le réel
et d'aller aussi chercher des gens qui
n'ont pas fait le choix de voir cette
exposition et qui la découvre et qui
peuvent être
interpol est interloqué curieux
normalement le chorégraphe était attendu
à la barbacane le 6 mars
mais la crise sanitaire oblige son
report sur la saison 2022 2023
d'ailleurs l'une des photos représentent
un de ses spectacles nommé tragédie dans
ce spectacle là le rapport au corps est
très important et il était question de
dépasser la question du corps de
l'interprète pour vraiment voir le
mouvement est donc on est dans un
spectacle très fort très percutant
l'exposition est à voir tous les jours
jusqu'au 6 mars prochain